what is up everybody welcome to the
first tutorial in the matte plot lib
tutorial series today i'm going to show
you guys just the most basic of just
getting some plots and graphing it
if you were like me originally all i
wanted to do and it was just i have some
some stuff i just want to plot it on my
computer i
i didn't really care about anything too
fancy i just wanted to plot some plots
and um if you're like me you're going to
do that and then later on you're going
to long to
make stuff colorful and have some
dynamic stuff to it maybe even get
live updates you know so the graph
itself refreshes automatically you don't
have to close and reopen and reload
so anyway what i'm going to do is just
start from these very very basics and
move along
right away what you're going to want to
do is you'll have to import
matplotlib
right now all we're doing is using pi
plot
and we want to import that as plt you
don't have to do this
you could import it as whatever you
wanted xxy if you wanted but generally
if you look anywhere for um
documents or examples this is how people
are going to denote matplotlib
and the other thing i suggest you get
i'm not going to show you guys at the
moment but uh numpy
you also import
uh numpy
as np however again we're not really
going to be using that in this tutorial
so i'm just going to comment it out
so and how do you get matplotlib if you
don't have it well this was probably one
of the easiest imports to get you just
go to
matplotlib.org let me get back to the
home for you
um and then you click on downloads and
then you come down here to whatever
version you have
if you listen to me in one of my others
or listen to just about anybody else you
probably have
python 2.7
and
i personally have win32 you might have
amd64 you'll have to figure that out on
your own or you could even have one of
these you could also download the
tarball
um
but if you the easiest thing is just use
the exe it works well although i will uh
just mention that if you do have
the
problem like if it says you you don't
have python installed
uh the way around that again is to go
into system control panel and you want
to edit your environmental variables so
you go to control panel i'm sorry system
advanced settings or something like that
environment variables and then you need
to add the python directory to your path
just how i think it's a semicolon and
then that directory
so anyways back to this
so we've imported map plot lib dot fly
pi plot as plt
so
all you have to do it's very very simple
all you have to do is you want to call
the
matplotlib.podclot with this and then
you want to tell it we want to plot
and so we're going to plot
our x will be 1 2 3 and 4
and then we'll plot y's the
corresponding y
4 7 9 and 12.
okay and you always always always have
to have an equal number of variables on
either side i mean that sounds uh common
sense but later on it can be kind of
hard like if you're matching up two x's
and because like later on usually what
ends up happening
is you have some sort of process that
identifies x so later on you'd have a
variable just called x and you'll have x
here and you'll have y here and that and
these will correspond to maybe a huge
list or a huge array and sometimes the
arrays don't match up in length and so
that'll be a problem later on you'll
almost certainly run into it at least
once and uh that'll be your problem
and then so once you've told it to plot
that the only other thing you have to do
is block show
and then you run this
and you'll get this pop up here and here
we go we've got all four plots here this
is the first second third and fourth now
you can do all kinds of fun fancy stuff
with matplotlib once you have more and
more data you you can use some of this
stuff but this is the zoom function you
just click on it you'll see this little
arrow and then you can zoom into plots
now we didn't like i said we don't
really have too many but you you still
can
um if you accidentally like you got here
where you want to be and then you're
like oh shoot i just misclicked or
whatever you can use the back function
if you miss click to the back function
like shoot you could go back forward
again it's kind of like a browser and
then if you just happen to get so lost
and you're just like oh gosh now i got
to reload it no you don't you can just
hit home and it takes you back to the
original image
um then you can also use this and it's
kind of like a click and drag you know
you can move this around
um up and down all that
um but again and again you know if you
do that you're like oh shoot i don't
want that you can do that
and finally this little button here
obviously no finally we still have to
save but the save is pretty pretty
simple you just save the picture you can
save it as anything you want you just
type it in and it's called a tagged
image file format but you can also just
take a screenshot using the print screen
i've never really used this but i think
you can saves like
dynamics of the picture or of the graph
if you uh wanted to
uh oh this okay this is the the only
useful part of this to me
it brings up this window oh shoot
i'm back
i hate windows shake uh i don't know
anybody else who has windows 7 but uh
this little like shake option like i'll
show you shake a window and everything
goes away
when i first got this i didn't know that
you could reshake it again and
everything would come back and i'd have
like maybe like 30 windows up and i'm
like oh my gosh i have to go open them
and stuff and then one of my buddies
that actually has a mac
uh told me to just shake it again and i
was just thoroughly
embarrassed
anyway um
okay so what this does is you can kind
of uh or like reshape this stuff so this
is the left and it
is usually corresponding to these the
actual chart itself so as you can see
there's the chart then you've got like
this like background space and then
you've actually got the frame or the
window right around here and so you can
say like okay left here i want this to
be like that and then from the bottom
you can do this kind of stuff
and uh
yeah i mean you get the point um
i'm not sure what w space is you know i
can't remember what this is i think it
has something to do with uh
if there's multiple like if there's
another chart here i want to say
it's the space between two charts
because sometimes like if you have too
many charts the numbers can overlap each
other and you still will override it by
squishing it like this but if you have a
lot of different charts
that's what that h space and w space is
and actually i can probably bring up one
of my charts and show you an example one
moment okay now
bear in mind these charts are um
well first of all you'll notice they're
color coded and stuff and these are also
live updating charts i believe it's on
like a
15 or 30 second timer so don't pay any
attention to that if they start changing
color on us but i just want to show you
the uh head space and that like width
spacer i'm not quite positive what they
stand for but i like to think of them as
head space and uh i don't know wide
space
so as you can see since like this chart
is actually made for a like my full
screen monitor so they're normally not
overlapping but now they are and so what
you can do is change this
person i'm not being able to edit this
stuff why won't you let me edit you
okay here we go
so you can say okay i don't want any and
so now they're allowed to just overlap
each other you can do the same thing
with this
and now they're allowed to just overlap
each other
um so if you're running out of space or
whatnot but generally you want to be
able to read your charts so you'd want
to make it maybe bigger so we can really
space them out anyway
um so really the purpose for head space
and white space um
or width space or whatever if you know
what the spit what the letters actually
stand for i just think that this is up
and down and side to side
what this will be used for for later is
you can actually hard code this stuff
right in so
like on that chart i have there it's
actually hard coded in but again no
matter how hard you coat it if you
squish the window up enough it'll still
disobey
but what you can do is just coat it in
so what you can do is use this window
and kind of mess with these
parameters to see something you kind of
like and then take these numbers and you
import
that into your script
so those are the basics to
putting up a chart now the next thing
um that you absolutely must have on
every chart
if you've been in uh grade school or
anything and you should know and take in
a math class that every uh graph has to
have what
a title
no matter what otherwise the teacher you
know took off a bunch of points from you
and so we'll just say matplot live
example title
okay
and then what else did you have to do
you had to label your x and y axes so
pretty simple uh x label
and we'll call this
plot x label
y
then you have to do your y label
move that plot y level
and now we'll save it and run it
and as you can see we have matplot
example title y label x label later on
you can do all kinds of stuff with this
you can affect the size the way it
angles um
you can affect the way the numbers angle
like if you have dates down here a lot
of times the dates will run over each
other so you can get them to be kind of
crooked and sideways-ish and so they fit
um we can change the color of the lawn
you can do all kinds of stuff so i'm
going to show you guys a few other
things on some later tutorials although
coloring is definitely not going to be
the next one i don't think um
the next most useful thing is not uh
hard coding your
your data because right now we're doing
this and so most people are going to
either have a notepad file or a an excel
file which really they're
interchangeable you could call an excel
a notepad or save a notepad as an excel
as long as it's comma separated it
doesn't really matter so
i'll show you guys how to load that
stuff in and continue plotting in the
next tutorial thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and stay tuned for
the next video